[Music]
either the day salutes you come out for me or with
your briefing on paying your
respects to the fallen it's going to be a little
different during this memorial day they
traditionally put flags on
each of the veterans' graves but
this won't happen because of  the pandemic
the cemetery staff says that it will be
very difficult if social distance must be respected
the public
can still visit them
today is the last day of tests to
stop the virus in oblivion since
this site will move to the
ivanov parking lot and  the new space will offer
tests for pedestrians
these are free and you do not need to make an
appointment
and more places are opening their doors
around the valley now it is the turn
of the neon museum this will reopen with new
security protocols and guidelines to
comply with social distancing
the union museum  he is also opening
three new versions of his show
william the themes reflect wild west
ham & tourism and the golden a ge from las
vegas
and now we pass with your forecast
a sunny day is expected with winds of 25
to 35 miles per hour the high today
will be in 91 degrees and tomorrow
we will drop to 80 before rising to
107 degrees next week
I am Salí Jaramillo and this was the news
now in Spanish
[Music]